Wow
how did Disney let that title get by I
remember every kid who read that title
is like holy Disney did what but
that's not the kind of story they're
telling when they say bulb they mean
make bigger and that's what the film is
about Rick Moranis is back and so is his
son the sister I guess is in college or
off-screen land and they have yet
another newcomer to welcome a little
baby boy that gets wound up in his
latest invention
and as you guess grows larger only they
can't seem to control it and he just
keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger until he's godzilla-sized can our
parents figure out a way to save them
before the military shoots him down Oh
what do you think
once again the movie is definitely a
showcase for some impressive effects
that even nowadays still hold up pretty
well and I get the feeling that the
first film probably got a lot of
complaints from parents saying Oh too
many scary images Oh too intense because
this one is the complete opposite
everything is really happy everything is
really cute oh look at the little baby
now he's big and he's running a rampage
teehee ha ha oh we bit the ice cream bar
cute and that's where the attitude this
one has really goofy and really childish
but he'll listen to the setup what do
you expect the first film was already a
little silly with its concept but this
one is especially silly there's a lot of
over-the-top acting there's a lot of
cutesy humor and again it's fine you can
show it to your kids and they can get
some laughs but as an adult I think
outside of some of the effects it's not
going to be as impressive where with the
first one it was creating an entire
world and weird creatures and all sorts
of strange things to come across here
they just made a baby big and they did a
well don't get me wrong but after a
while it kind of wears off and is not as
interesting as the first one but I guess
it could have been a lot worse Rick
Moranis is still funny the kid has grown
up and is no longer a dweeby scientist
but instead wants to be a rock musician
which is odd there's a baby Sara that
gets roped into it literally and like I
said there's one or two
funny visuals with it but it's nowhere
as interesting as the first one and it
is one of those sequels that really
didn't need to exist but if you're
interesting you just want to show your
kid a little something that's kind of
funny and has some neat effects it's not
bad to check out but for anyone that
really enjoyed the world and the size of
the first one
this film will definitely leave you
wanting something bigger